Sears once America's largest employer is
now fighting to stay in business its
chairman promised again yesterday to
line up financing to save the classic
retailer his new offer goes to an
auction on Monday competing against
other bidders who want to shut down the
company Sears had just under 700 stores
and about 68,000 employees as of late
last year it filed bankruptcy in October
during a record wave of retail store
closings Tony Tecopa looks at how sears
his troubles affect shoppers and workers
alike Tony good morning good morning
Sears once employed as many as 350,000
people offering workers a path to the
middle class and customers a little bit
of luxury at middle-class prices now
roughly 68,000 Sears employees are
wondering what's next as millions of
shoppers move on
it was the original everything retailer
delivering the world to your doorstep
decades before anyone ever got a box
from Amazon why do I shop at Sears it's
easy for me I can pick up tennis balls
children's clothing
Tork branches but after navigating the
shift to department stores and malls
Sears stopped innovating according to
former Sears executive Mark Cohen now
director of the retail studies program
at Columbia Business School the company
has been on a death spiral for well over
a decade it lost sight of the fact that
change is a constant while he blames
poor management and stiff competition
for the demise of Sears it's not the
only company that has failed to change
with the times from 2012 through 2017 us
ecommerce sales nearly doubled and in
the last two years at least 200 million
square feet of retail space closed
including dozens of stores from JCPenney
Macy's Toys R Us and Kmart which merged
with Sears in 2005 Sears itself has
shuttered more than 3000 stores
worldwide in the past decade this table
and chairs and the china cabinet came
from Sears Bobby Jones told CBS Sunday
morning he worked at Sears for 35 years
enjoying wages and benefits that many of
today's retail workers can only dream of
prestige to say yes now while the
decline of Sears may be historic says
CBS News financial contributor Mellody
Hobson it does not mean the death of
retail you have lots of retailers that
are thriving out there and you have some
like Amazon that are building
brick-and-mortar stores like Whole Foods
which they acquired but should any of
today's retail giants fail to adapt
Hobson says they too risk falling you
have to be able to play in lots of lanes
online with brick-and-mortar you have to
have good products that the customer
wants and stay competitive as for Sears
last month a court approved bonuses of
up to twenty five million dollars for
Sears executives willing to work through
the bankruptcy the company's frontline
employees meanwhile are worried they may
walk away with nothing the hedge fund
hoping to buy Sears says it expects to
reinstate the severance program in place
prior to the bankruptcy but the key word
there of course is expects biana
yeah Tony thank you and you know we're
talking about some 50,000 jobs that are
on the line here but as you mentioned
that company has been on life support
for many many years we've all had so
many memories here yeah it's still
joining to me be honored to see the the
storefront with the word Sears store
closing yeah yeah like a lot of memories
for those insured oh yea survival of the
fittest in this industry exactly